Vanadium is going to have a new use.
I read about it just a short time ago in a chemistry journal.
It said that Bismuth Vanadate is a new, environmentally more friendly, less poisonous yellow pigment.
So I looked up some recipes and it talked about controlled PH precipitation of the compound.
but
We thought we'd just try it without controlling anything.
A pigment is the colouring material you put in paints and other coatings.
Some of the best yellow pigments like Lead Chromate or Cadmium Sulphide are very poisonous.
Now, of course people don't necessarily start eating the wings of their cars and things like that,
but on the other hand, it is much better if you can use pigments that are non-toxic or have very low toxicity,
and Lead Chromate in particular, has Chromium 6 which is very poisonous and it has Lead so it is doubly cursed.
Bismuth is relatively non-toxic and so is Vanadium.
So Bismuth Vanadate, which is in effect, a mixed oxide of Bismuth and Vanadium, is relatively harmless.
Now, I'm not suggesting that you should eat it
But
If you had a choice of eating that or Lead Chromate I know which one I would choose.
I wanted to do a real experiment.
I got a student along to come and help me.
Erica, who is one of my students
and her hand is steadier than mine.
And of course, when I get excited I shake even more
So, we mixed, Bismuth Nitrate and Ammonium Metavanadate.
And, much to our surprise, the first experiment produced a really nice orange - yellow precipitate.
And It's
really surprising for me as a Chemist. You take two solutions that are almost colourless,
the Bismuth is completely colourless
and the Vanadium is just very pale yellow,
and suddenly you get this brilliant colour, out of nothing. So that was really quite a surprise.
I got so excited, I went round the lab. We were in a teaching lab showing other people. (Look)
It's very easy to make
And I guess, that depending how you make it, you can probably alter the colour a bit.
Make it a bit more orange, a bit more yellow.
But,
It's really nice to see, simple Chemistry like that, suddenly having important new uses.
So in a year or two's time, you can probably get Bismuth Vanadate on your cars, your saucepans or whatever.